hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others and I see
a variety of questions here
um
here's a question here from desks
suppose I wanted to store Digital Data
in a way that would be accessible to
archaeologists 10 000 years in the
future how can I achieve this
suggesting
thin aluminum or titanium Punch Cards
etc etc etc
um
okay it's an interesting problem so
you know how does one communicate things
across large periods of time
it's something where we can get some
sense from looking at archaeological
history
going back
4 000 years maybe 10 000 years maybe a
little bit longer and the main
conclusion is it's really hard
it's something where there are a couple
of issues one is the thing that you are
uh
putting data into something that will
survive and another is will anybody
understand what the data means or even
that it is Data so let's talk first of
all about what survives
you know rock survives for a really long
time Stone survives for a really long
time the uh
there are rocks Exposed on the earth
that are you know a a couple of billion
years old most rockers is considerably
younger than that and there's a
continual process of of new rock being
being pushed up from uh from from the
mantle of the earth and so on
um but there is rock that is I think
um as I recall a couple of billion years
old because there are fossils that
um come from uh when life first emerged
on the earth which was probably maybe
2.6 billion years ago or something on
the moon the the surface is
original so to speak except where
there's a crater because some something
crashed into the moon so that means that
the surface of the Moon is 4.6 billion
years old uh give or take so it's
something where
if you want to you know that there are
things you can put
on uh the rock lasts a really long time
there are things you can put that will
last a long time so for example uh
things like quartz
form of Rock with etching in it would
last a really long time for example on
the moon
actually the friend of mine who's had a
project uh to take
um random kind of beacons of our
civilization and put them around the
solar system uh even another group of
people I know who are trying to get them
into the interstellar space
but um uh the um
the the the the question of what you put
there first question is you need
something where the actual sort of
writing or whatever it is Will Survive
uh for a long period of time and you can
do that by etching things on things like
quotes on various kinds of metal
um and in fact uh there are even copies
of books of mine in microscopic form
etched into I guess it's a uh it's some
kind of metal disc that
um might have made it to the moon I'll
tell you the story of that in a moment
um the uh and uh there's some other
things like that that made it at least
into the the trunk of the Tesla car that
got launched into out into the into the
solar system a few years ago
um
but so that's the question of of what uh
the the physical object how long does it
last well the answer is you can probably
have physical objects that last for
billions of years if they're not in
places that uh have bad things happening
to them now there are some things that I
know haven't gone quite so well like for
example in the Apollo missions uh there
are these proud uh American flags that
got taken by the Apollo Astronauts and
and put you know on the moon it's always
a bit of a mystery when you see a
picture of a flag on the moon the moon
has no atmosphere no air and uh a flag
flutters in the air you know flutters in
the wind so how come the flag that's on
the moon is is nicely kind of uh
unfilled and uh
um and sort of uh displayed with with
full flagness so to speak well the
answer is it had to have a piece of wire
at the top to keep it in that
configuration because there's no air on
the moon to be to be blowing the flag
out but uh I I gather that it's believed
at least that the the flags that were
put there the flag itself the physical
object is absolutely still there after
50 years or whatever it is
um but the uh the design of you know the
stars and stripes and so on on the flag
is gone the thing will probably be white
and the reason for that is that the dies
that um uh were used to make the flag
um have been uh the the the there are
enough uh kind of cosmic rays and other
things that hit the moon charged
particles mostly from the Sun electrons
protons and so on mostly from the Sun
streaming out along with the light from
the Sun hitting the moon and those
things destroyed the probably the dyes
that were used in in that it's the same
kind of phenomenon
um as that if you have uh books which
are exposed to the sun they will uh
gradually lose their color uh usually
the red dye goes first
um not quite sure why actually I think
it may just be because the chemistry of
the red dye uh maybe
um probably that but some thought
required there and then maybe there may
be an easier way to understand that but
any case so so printing something in in
color dye not a good idea if you wanted
to survive a long time even in 50 years
on the moon it hasn't survived uh but
you know having a thing sort of set in
stone so to speak you can have that
survive if nothing comes and sort of uh
destroys it could survive for a billion
years potentially
uh you know we see that in kind of the
archaeological remains from you know a
few thousand years ago whether it's
pyramids or whether it's uh you know
temples and things or other buildings
from um uh uh from Antiquity on on Earth
the thing that's always struck me is
that you know you go and look at the
Roman ruins and things like that and
they have a certain form and you kind of
have this idea or that's kind of what
the thing was like but it's actually
hard to imagine what uh the uh the city
was like when it was really whole so to
speak because there was a lot of stuff
that was wood and a lot of brightly
colored things no doubt that were there
and I'm sure it looked uh all rather
impressive and so on I have to say many
many years ago now I lived in California
for a while and uh was in a place where
the house I had was almost burnt down by
a a fire
um but the fire happened to and this uh
our house but unfortunately but it
burned down a lot of houses in the in
the area
and the thing that was really striking
to me was you know I know what these
houses more or less looked like when
they were kind of whole so to speak but
after this fire you drove through this
fire area and all that was left were a
bunch of foundations of houses and those
foundations looked in an awfully lot
like the kinds of foundations that one
sees when one looks at Roman ruins and
so on and so color of the translation of
what these houses looked like when they
were whole versus what one was seeing
post fire kind of gives one some sense
sort of reversing that because on some
sense of how different the these things
in Antiquity probably looked in in real
life but any case so you know so we've
got these things they're kind of set in
stone and then we asked the question
well what does all these what are all
these squiggles on these pieces of stone
what do they mean can we understand them
and uh you know there are places where
people are very interested in that
question for the future for example when
people are uh burying radioactive waste
from nuclear reactors you really kind of
want a sign that says keep out of here
while it's still radioactive and that
might be 10 000 years and so there's
sort of a question of can you make a
sign that could plausibly be understood
10 000 years into the future even
assuming that sort of human civilization
is not that different from the way it is
today in the sense that you know let's
say going back 5 000 years human
civilization was sort of vaguely similar
to what it is today
well that's challenging and you know if
one asks the question what do these
various things mean going back in the
past it's it's really really difficult
you know I was really struck a few years
ago I happened to be in in Peru in um
visiting some archaeological site that
there's a very old um site I think it's
one of the oldest places in the Americas
that has kind of existing archaeological
remains and uh it was a rather abandoned
site actually but but um the person who
was showing us around I kept on saying
you know what was that thing for and
they would say it was for ceremonial
purposes
translation and we have no translation
from Modern Times to what on Earth this
thing was for it is you know it's
completely whatever was its purpose that
purpose is now lost to us culture has
changed the point where we we don't
understand what it is and there are
plenty of things we can imagine from the
current time I mean I don't know you
could say what's the uh significance of
well I mean you could take the Eiffel
Tower or the Washington Monument or
something like that what is it for well
it's just a monument well the Eiffel
Tower wasn't the Eiffel Tower originally
was a great big ad for things like
Bridge Building Technology
um and uh you know but that purpose is
lost in that case but it's really hard
to have a translation of purpose I mean
that's very short periods of time it's
hard to have this translation of purpose
across sort of archaeological history
one of the more striking examples that I
know of this is uh there's a uh thing I
think it's in Aleppo in Syria there's a
a a sort of a wall which has paint still
on it it was in a cave and um the paint
is black and red and it's a bunch of
squares and the squares are in some
arrangement and it's like what on Earth
is this it's from 11 000 years ago you
know what was somebody thinking when
they made this we have no idea there are
similarly there are hand prints and
caves painted paint hand prints and
caves you know are they just was was it
just somebody who was or some group of
people who were sort of randomly you
know dipping their hands and painting
sticking them on the edge of the cave or
was the pattern of these hands some
incredibly significant thing that
related to some you know Grand ceremony
or some some other thing that was
happening there we don't know
and the places where we kind of do know
where there is for example language
that's been been passed down well we
have some idea when there's a
representational picture of somebody you
know hunting an animal or something
insofar as that representation has
remained more or less constant to today
we can recognize it and part of the
reason it's remained constant is that
when we draw a picture we're not keeping
sort of every pixel just like it was if
we took a photograph we're interpreting
it and showing the edges much more
strongly than we're showing the interior
of things and so on we're we're kind of
making a sketch based on the actual
visual form that we see but our biology
has remained constant over very long
periods of time actually and the ways
that our eyes pick out edges and things
like that have remained very constant I
mean not just for humans but but going
back probably hundreds of millions of
years into evolutionary history kind of
the Basic Hardware that's been used to
process images in our brains has remain
pretty much the same and that means that
the the picture that what somebody chose
to highlight in into at least in terms
of you know making the outlines of the
animals and things is pretty much the
same as today
I could imagine something where somebody
had drawn a a form of picture where oh I
don't know you know some some pieces of
of quotes Modern Art where in their
moment people were knowing oh yes that's
a reference to this cultural thing and
it's a not a soup can but it's some
other you know cultural reference of the
day and uh you know it is not directly
representational art and at a different
time it will be completely lost what on
Earth that was referring to
well so you know there's a there's a big
challenge of sort of understanding
across history what things mean and I
think that um uh the um
the thing that um
um
is there are particular languages where
we can see what this meant and sometimes
there are there are challenges and
sometimes well for example hieroglyphics
the the language of ancient Egypt
um the uh uh there was a question of how
was that decoded it was decoded in the
1800s and a key thing was that the
Rosetta Stone was found which contained
uh the same passage uh kind of given in
three different languages it's kind of
like that was the early version of the
machine learning way of learning
language translation in modern times
like between European languages they're
just you know gobs of of pages of EU
regulations that are translated into the
many languages of the European Union and
the fact that there is this sort of
parallel text between those different
languages is how the machine Learning
Systems learn to do language translation
it's actually not just regulatory stuff
from governments it's also things like
computer manuals and websites and so on
that have been translated but it's sort
of amusing that the way that Egyptian
hieroglyphs got decoded is really sort
of the same idea except that now it's
billions of pages of text and then it
was just one big you know stone slab
that's now in the British museum so to
speak
um but you know there were other
forms of ancient writing that have been
very difficult to decode linear a linear
B from Crete uh was that was a big thing
in what the 1930s 1940s
um when that was when one of those was
decoded the other one has never been
decoded I don't remember which one is
which but um uh and there are other
places and things where we have things
that sort of look like writing but it's
never been decoded what that means and
usually to have a sort of a decoding you
have to have kind of this thread of
history that connects one back to that
that time not only in terms of the
writing but also in terms of the
concepts that are being expressed there
you know I I think I I skipped over
something I wanted to say which was
about
um stuff that gets to survive for long
periods of time and I was mentioning the
moon as a place where you can keep stuff
for long periods of time at least until
the moon becomes a tourist destination
and um everybody's picking up all the
artifacts and so on and saying oh this
is really cool it's been here for 200
years
um now I'll pick it up
um but uh if that's not
being done on the uh uh then you know in
in terms of just being there if nobody's
disturbing it it will stay for a long
time I was mentioning that some some
stuff of mine that was on these uh I
guess they're metal discs
um that might have made it to the moon I
should have explained what I mean by
might have made it and this was probably
almost at 2018 I think there was uh a
spacecraft actually an Israeli private
spacecraft that
um was going to the moon the bearishat
Lander and uh it um
uh uh this friend of mine had managed to
hitch a ride for the package from his uh
it's called the arch Mission Arc Arch
mission project of of kind of delivering
little packets of uh material for Mass
civilization
um to to be stored in places around the
solar system well anyway that the
package got put on the Lander
unfortunately the Lander uh crashed into
the moon at about what was it
um 2000 kilometers an hour I think
um the uh uh something you know when
you're gonna land something on something
like the moon it's in orbit around the
Moon it was an orbit around the Moon it
has to you know when you're in orbit
you're going round at a certain speed
for low earth orbit it's like 17 000
miles an hour Luna Robert I think it's 5
000 miles an hour if I'm not mistaken as
the is the speed that you're going in
sort of low lunar orbit and in order to
actually land on the moon you have to
stop going around and just start going
straight down so to speak and you have
to go straight down and stop before you
hit the surface well unfortunately in
the case of this spacecraft it seemed
not to have managed to to sort of stop
going around really fast and it crashed
into the surface at I think it was about
2 000 kilometers an hour if I remember
correctly
um and the question is well what happens
to a spacecraft that uh crashes into the
moon at 2000 kilometers per hour and you
might say it's it doesn't have a hope
and uh it'll be vaporized and in fact
somebody I know who had had a rocket
company which had a proportional rather
unsuccessful launches gave me the
analogy of imagine that you take the
main gun from a battleship and you fire
it a shell into a piece of concrete
that's the effect that you will have at
that speed
well and so it seemed hopeless
then actually a few weeks later the
lunar reconnaissance Orbiter which takes
high resolution imagery of lunar surface
went by and it it saw the The Landings
the crash site
and uh I I sort of got curious because
we realized that that because the thing
was was kind of going had not really
de-orbited the moon properly it was
still going at a very it was still going
sort of um uh skating along the surface
of the Moon at a high speed it was going
down but it was also going along the
surface very quickly
and I uh found a person who um uh was an
expert in cratering
um and uh asked uh kind of what would
actually happen this was I think I think
we worked out it was about a 15 degree
angle I think when it hit the moon
um and you know what happens at that
speed when you hit the moon and and we'd
worked out there was a a lost picture
that had been taken
um of the lunar Surface by the
spacecraft and from that picture you can
see the configuration of craters you can
figure out where that picture was taken
then you can figure out where the crash
site was from the pictures from the
Ruiner reconnaissance Orbiter you can
just make a line between those you can
see what the direction thing was going
in and so you can see when it hit the
moon where was it kind of skating along
the surface of the Moon
so I I for various reasons I I think um
uh somehow I ended up doing the
calculation of what would happen to a
thing that hits the moon at that speed
and et cetera et cetera et cetera well
if if all else if it was just a thing
that was going on the moon at that that
speed and so on you can work out based
on the friction of a thing sort of just
rolling along the Moon it would have
gone for a couple of kilometers before
it stopped assuming it didn't run into a
boulder and go Splat and so on but
anyway that the person was an expert on
cratering told me that at that angle
things just bounce it they don't if
they're coming in sort of straight down
to the Moon yes they just go Splat on
the naked crater but if they are coming
at that acute an angle they kind of skid
along the surface of the Moon and in
fact having knowing that one can look at
the pictures from the lunar
reconnaissance Orbiter and we can see
that yes there's this lovely Ray that
you can see in the picture which kind of
goes out in exactly the direction you
would expect from the crash site now
what makes that light array not so clear
because the lunar surface is covered
with this kind of sand like stuff lunar
regolith and what makes the thing when
it's been sort of abraded turn lighter
wasn't totally clear but it's at least
something was changed there so anyway
the the expectation is that the little
package of sort of interesting things
from our civilization on I guess quartz
disks and metal discs and so on
um uh probably actually survive the
crash and it probably skiddled along the
lunar surface and it's sitting somewhere
somewhere on the moon
um
so in any case the question of whether
anybody will understand what's in it at
any point in the future if one goes you
know uh thousands of years into the
future is a quite separate question a
lot of that question depends on the
future of human civilization which is
quite a separate issue but if we just
ask sort of from history what kind of
thing would likely lead to that kind of
sort of long time understanding it's an
interesting question
you know people have done some slightly
goofy things in my opinion along these
lines people when the first spacecraft
was sent into the outer solar system and
beyond there was sort of the question of
what should you put on them that would
kind of talk about how wonderful uh our
civilization is and so on and so the uh
the Pioneer spacecraft that are now the
two of them that are now far outside the
solar system and I guess we've lost
contact with those particular spacecraft
at this point
um the uh
yeah I think that that's that's right I
launched like 40-ish years ago
um the uh
those spacecraft have these plaques on
them which were intended to kind of be a
uh uh well you could say a thing where
uh you know on the spacecraft it could
say you know property of the human
species on Planet X but um no they were
they were plaques that were intended to
represent something about uh the human
human civilization and knowledge I don't
think they were terribly successful I
mean of course we don't know then
nobody's nobody uh has come saying oh we
found your plaques uh you know and and
this is what we think based on them but
um they had a very strange
representation of uh uh kind of the the
solar system and the possession of a you
know picture of a couple of people and
things like this and then I think one of
the one of the worst parts of this
plaque was
there needed to be a way of representing
distance in order to kind of give a
sense of if this if this spacecraft is
found a billion years from now somewhere
else in the Galaxy there's the question
of where did it come from and the
the idea was to show the position of the
Earth by using the its position relative
to pulsars relative to neutron stars
rapidly rotating neutral rotating
neutron stars that produce intense radio
emissions
and the I actually now I'm wondering if
you really waited a billion years I'm
sure those pulsars are all in completely
different positions because there's the
rotation of the Galaxy every every few
hundred million years and I I don't
think it doesn't rotate rigidly enough I
think they end up in different places so
I'm not even sure that that makes much
sense but assume the pulsars are still
roughly in the same place it's actually
a thing people imagine using in the near
term as a sort of uh interplanetary GPS
system because GPS is based on
satellites in orbit around the Earth and
so if you're far away from the earth you
don't get to use the the you know it's
not useful to use the terrestrial even
if you could pick up radio signals from
them those radio signals will just give
you information from knowing the
distance to the satellites in different
places in Earth orbit and if you're out
in the orbit of of Jupiter for example
that doesn't really do me much good so
you have to use some more Global Way of
tell where things are and one thing you
can do potentially is to look at the
directions to pulsars and that can tell
you where you are in the solar system
but anyway this was the this was a kind
of pictorial version of that and so one
of the issues was to mark off what the
actual distance to these different
pulsars is and there's a question of
what what is the unit of length that you
use
so
the thing that I consider this the worst
part of this plaque was to make a
specification of what the length was now
you might have thought you would just
draw a line of that length or it might
be the size of the spacecraft or
something like this that would be the
length measure but no it was not instead
on this plaque there's a picture uh that
shows
um kind of two circles and one of them
has an arrow pointing up and one of them
has an arrow pointing down I think I'm
remembering this correctly uh and
that's somehow supposed to indicate
the uh a measure of distance well the
problem is what is that well if you're a
physicist from the 20th century and you
were educated in quantum mechanics
you might possibly have seen book
pictures a bit like that in quantum
mechanics books
that what that was supposed to represent
is a phenomenon in quantum mechanics the
so-called hyperfine splitting of
hydrogen the the um it is the the thing
that happens when you have electrons
have a spin their little particles of
charge with charge and they also spin
around on their axis at least in some
conceptual sense and when protons do the
same thing when the protons and
electrons in a hydrogen atom are aligned
the hydrogen atom has one level of
energy when they're anti-aligned it has
a different amount of energy because
it's like having bar magnets where the
bar magnets you the bar magnets like to
arrange themselves you know not if this
if one bar magnet is North is up South
is down for its poles then you put a bar
magnet next to it it will like to be
South as up north is down same with
electrons and protons and so there's a
an energy difference and that energy
difference when a hydrogen atom makes
the transition from one of those energy
states to the other it emits a photon
emits a photon that has is a radio
frequency Photon that has a wavelength
of about 21 centimeters and that that
picture was a representation of the
electron proton spin flip transition you
know imagine to be emitting a photon of
wavelength 21 centimeters and so the the
answer you know to the the quiz so to
speak was the measure of length was 21
centimeters but the problem with that is
that that whole representation of
electrons with arrows and things like
this is an incredibly human specific
20th century physics specific
interpretation not least because the way
electron spin works and so on it's not
really rotation it's really it's this
notion of a spinner it's a complicated
kind of mathematical construct that it
just happened to be a convenient thing
to think about in terms of a direction
and arrows and things and that was the
way it was first imagined in the 1920s
but doesn't necessarily have to work
that way in our model of physics for
example the natural representation of
that kind of thing would probably be
something completely different
so it's a to my mind it's kind of a goof
in terms of being able to represent uh
sort of something in a in a Time
invariate way because you're really
locking it down to 20th century physics
which is presumably not the
intergalactic standard of um of
representation of physics
so
then well then came the um
am I getting these the wrong way around
which came first pioneer or Voyager I'm
I'm forgetting maybe maybe it's I know I
think Voyager came second as a deep
space probe
um uh I always used to be a big
Enthusiast of this spacecraft when I was
a kid but I think these ones were
launched right after I was a kid I knew
I knew about the spacecraft that the
first spacecraft that went to Mars and
Venus and places like that
um and I could no doubt tell you all
about uh I haven't thought about it in
in more than 50 years but but uh you
know Mariner 4 spacecraft that went to
Mars and so on it's worth remembering
just in terms of how history evolves
that when I was a kid let's say that
spacecraft was probably
1965 1966 something like that uh people
still were pretty convinced that there
was Life on Mars and that there were
that one was seeing as the seasons on
Mars changed one was seeing the uh these
different uh vegetation colors showing
up in different parts of the Martian
surface and it's worth remembering that
that um when the Viking Landers landed
in probably in
1976-ish time frame
um the maybe a little earlier than that
uh many people
were you know kind of expecting they
would find microorganisms in the Martian
soil and the fact that you know people
it was generally thought it's probably
the case that there's Life on Mars
um and it was sort of uh uh it's that
recent that
um one sort of has thought that there
probably isn't uh at least not in any
form that can easily be recognized so to
speak so
uh but back to this question of of sort
of transmitting information over long
periods of time so in the Voyager
spacecraft
there was a um uh let's show off the
Earth's achievements there was a a
record a phonograph type record
um you know thing with uh
I don't even know how to describe this
anymore because it's like I would say
it's like a CD but people might not even
know what CDs are anymore the um
um rotating
um thing that had little grooves in it
that uh was the original way that record
players gramophones whatever worked
um back in certainly when I was a kid
there will be plastic vinyl
um uh records and um
they have little grooves in them and a
big Helix and there's a a a
um uh a stylus with a needle at the end
which would kind of ride around that
Groove in this Helix and depending on
the height of the the the the thing
would be sort of etched out
um and depending on the height at a
particular place and that
in that Groove
you would get
um uh different sound intensity
excuse me
so in any case that was you know to
somebody in the 1960s 1970s even
a
a record player
was a completely obvious kind of piece
of technology
the stylus it rides the helical uh
helical grooves it um uh you know plays
a sound based on the the height so on
the Voyager spacecraft there was a
record that had recorded a bunch of
music from around the world that was
recorded in this kind of way
okay well in today's world even right
now you know 45 50 years later it's like
a weird object it's like how do you play
this thing if I had one of these uh you
know you can obviously still get sort of
traditional record players but it's it's
a dwindling kind of thing it's a it's a
it's a you know uh buy it only as a
retro kind of uh kind of thing to do
and on that particular spacecraft there
was sort of a diagrammatic explanation
of how you play the record and I must
say I think it was even in today it's
sort of incomprehensible
um because it sort of had an implicit
assumption about well everybody knows
how these how these phonograph records
kind of work
you know to give a sense of the times uh
when I was a kid uh probably age 15 or
something I happened to spend a week or
two at a company in England that was
thinking about making video discs uh
this was at a time when there were you
know there were uh Records that were
um
there were like I think they had 33
revolutions per minute is that right and
then there were 78 Revolution per minute
smaller records and so on but the idea
was to put make a video disc where there
would be uh kind of um
uh the thing will be spinning fast
enough you could have enough data on it
that you could encode the uh the
information for a video the problem was
that records had this habit they're made
of plastic they had this habit of
picking up static electricity and so you
would end up with this big static
electric charge and the problem was if
you spin it very quickly it's just a
feature of of moving charges that they
produce uh that they'll they'll have and
the with a current flowing through the
stylus they would have a
electromagnetic force on the stylus and
so depending on how much static
electricity there was on the surface of
the spinning video disk like record you
would you would have a certain different
amount of force pushing the stylus up or
not and the problem was if something
were to discharge the electricity that
was on the surface of this record the
stylus will be pushed down with some
force and wouldn't respond quickly
enough it would just grind itself into
the record so the question was what were
it's an early practical physics project
of mine was uh what you know to
understand the static electricity and to
even be able to measure uh sort of where
the static electricity was on the record
was it at the surface
was it somehow embedded in the interior
of the plastic and so on so I had this
lovely experiment which I'm not sure if
it was ever done
um that involved figuring out by
dissolving the record in some uh very
aggressive solvent
um being able to figure out where the
actual charge and the thing was
um but in any case in the end the
technology of video discs got built the
videos disks were built for a short
while but they worked differently and
they didn't involve physical uh
physically touching the surface of the
disk
um they were involved a laser being able
to just like like a CD a laser just
being able to well and that was what how
DVDs worked subsequently
um the uh uh a laser just seeing
different
um
um uh different
um uh transparency of the material in
different places rather than a physical
thing riding on these grooves
but in any case back to the question of
how do you make something that people
are going to understand 10
000 years in the past ten thousand years
in the future whatever
um I think it's super challenging you
have
uh there are
there are all sorts of interesting
examples I I wrote a piece a few years
ago actually about this
um in connection with the original
effort to send little sort of beacons of
stuff around the solar system it's like
what do you put there that has any hope
of being unable to be understood outside
of our very specific uh sort of point in
in the history of civilization
I mean I should add that that the whole
idea of you know the aliens are like us
and they're going to be able to read
this stuff I I really don't think it's
right at all I think there's this kind
of uh distance between us as um
um the uh
um
uh the sort of us and our way of
thinking about the universe and other
ways of thinking about the universe that
distance is quite great and it's uh the
notion of what it counts to have as
being sort of an alien I think is uh
intelligence is a very very messy one so
I don't think it's I think the the
question of sort of how far apart are
the alien civilizations both in physical
space like how many light years away
than different stars and so on plus how
far away and what a corollial space the
sort of spaces of different
interpretations of the universe are they
and if they're far away in the different
interpretations of the universe they can
seem to us like something just
completely incomprehensible
um but in any case but ignoring that
issue by the way I see a comment here
that people commenting that final
records are becoming more common again
okay great so then by the time somebody
can go out and uh
um you know Chase off to the Voyager
spacecraft and capture them the the the
people will understand what um the
people who go do that will understand
what the instructions for the record
player
um actually actually meant
um in any case the um
I think um uh it's um
so
uh talking about some
um
what
um it was kind of talking about what
what you can do to make something that's
understandable over long periods of time
looking back at archaeological history
uh
there are all sorts of places where
people tried to sort of put messages for
the distant future I think one of the
more interesting ones four thousand
years ago or something now in Babylonian
times for example people who would build
some some big structure a temple a
citadel whatever it was they would
always put a message you know in the
foundations that said basically to
anybody who's destroyed this object you
know uh you're cursed more or less
um you know to to imagining that
somebody will come in as maybe they had
in conquering some other place and
destroy the structures there it's like
well when you destroy it right down to
the bottom you get to a message saying
you know you're cursed more or less
but people would put up
um
these different uh
these different things there's one
famous one let's see Darius King of the
Persians I think had this big sort of uh
um Big well not quite a plaque it's it's
on the side of a mountain somewhere in I
think Iran now
um where I was kind of recited the the
the great acts well at least the acts of
conquest of this chapterius and I think
it it begins in sort of a famous thing
as it begins you know I am I think
Darius you know King of Kings
Etc et cetera Etc
there's a the uh you know in in the kind
of uh cultural
collection there's this uh Chalet poem
that's about a somewhat different thing
it's about I think that's about Ramesses
II an Egyptian king
who um uh that's a it's a it's a poem I
always liked this woman I was a kid
um I don't know why I liked it it's sort
of sort of a downer of a poem because
it's basically says that there's this
you know
that there was this giant statue it's
now in the desert and um uh you know I
think the poem talks about too vast and
trunkless legs of stone so it's the legs
are still there and um uh and then
you know somewhere at the at the base of
this big statue or former statue is this
um uh is this plaque you know I am
ozamandias I think that was another name
for Ramesses
King of Kings look on my works you
mighty and despair
and of course you know this is a
reference to the fact that uh you know
at the time that was intended to be look
at all this great stuff I built nobody
else will be able to match it and by the
time it's found archaeologically so to
speak very little is left and one could
read that in a different way of the fact
that it's it's uh you know whatever
Empire there was there has crumbled and
so it goes with such things but in any
case that this um this kind of whole
question of what do you put and you know
what do you say and and even when you
read kind of the the thing I think of
some Darius
um this this whole sort of thing about
is military conquests and all this kind
of thing it reads in a very silly way in
a sense to us today it's not it's not
the way something will be written today
um and you know cultural difference uh
to that time but I think in um in this
question of of even knowing sort of that
something was put there on purpose even
knowing that this thing that you had
that um was a was an actual thing that
had human thought put into it so to
speak it's not trivial I mean you know
you find a flint from a million years
ago or something like this and it's like
was this a flint that was carefully
napped by some predecessor of ours or is
it just a flint that broke off from
something and lay on the ground and you
see that quite a bit with people asking
you know was this something made by I
don't know even Native Americans from
not that long ago was this you know way
that this this piece of uh of earthwork
was was organized actually I remember
when I was a kid in England there were
um you know you would see these pits in
in woods particularly really and it was
very unclear whether these pits were
fortifications from Neolithic times
places where bombs had fallen in World
War II or something completely different
and you know it's very hard to tell what
uh whether this you know the Mounds of
Earth that have been put there uh what
what was kind of the the thinking behind
um what uh what was going on there and I
think it's a it's a very challenging
thing to see when was their purpose in
something it's a this whole question
about the identification of purpose and
things is a is a very interesting
philosophical and practical question I
mean in a sense it's kind of like asking
uh it's it's you know it's a it's a it's
a version of was this thing done
nefariously by somebody for some
particular purpose or didn't just happen
that way or is there a if you're kind of
trying to find you know the lost city of
Atlantis or something under the ocean
somewhere you know and you're scanning
pieces of the ocean it's like can you
tell if if that rock you know
arrangement of rocks at the bottom of
the ocean was actually the Citadel of
Atlantis or whether it was just a random
pile of rocks
um produced by oceanographic or
geological processes so there are lots
of interesting questions around that
let's see
um
oh boy
uh
let's see if there's some memes is
commenting I wonder how vinyl would hold
up in um uh in space
I don't know the answer to that I I
think
um
uh
I was just actually just talking to a
friend of mine who's making some stuff
that's going on a Jupiter probe and um
uh the the thing has it's an antenna
assembly and has epoxy resin in it and
they were just testing it by putting it
so Jupiter has a very strong magnetic
field and it collects it a lot of
charged particles from the Sun get
trapped in that magnetic field so
there's intense radiation around Jupiter
and um so then the question is what
happens to epoxy resin when it's put in
intense radiation so apparently they've
been testing it by putting it next to a
nuclear reactor somewhere which has lots
of radiation coming from it to see what
will happen to epoxy resin I I don't
know the answer but that would be some
kind of proxy perhaps for knowing what
would happen to a vinyl record in in uh
when bombarded with lots of cosmic rays
and things like this
um
let's see
oh boy all right I'm gonna try and pick
out some questions that are sort of
related to things I've been talking
about pequil asks could the Earth ever
get a second moon what kinds of effects
could this have you know the question
one of my kids asked when they were very
young was um when there were dinosaurs
could the Earth have had two moons
and I I kind of use that as an example
of a question that sounds really
straightforward but it's actually really
hard to answer and I think the answer
that particular question is the earth
couldn't have had two moons 65 million
years ago but possibly a billion years
ago this could still have another
another Moon which got um maybe a couple
billion years ago there could have been
um that got torn out of the orbit and uh
or crashed into the moon as the Moon is
um and uh you know something did crash
into the moon because one part one side
of the Moon is really very different
from the rest of the Moon
um and there are theories about how the
moon formed the the big Splat Theory
seems to be the popular one that
something crashed into the earth the
earth you know a lot of stuff got
vaporized got got
liquefied it all went out into space one
piece of it condensed into the moon one
another part of it is is the Earth and
so on but
um uh this question of whether one could
have had a second moon that got uh sort
of ripped away from the earth by
something uh or or crashed into the moon
for example
um is still kind of an open question if
you go far enough back could the Earth
capture another thing that is a
moon-like thing well
the main problem is things that just
sort of wander by tend to be going
pretty fast
you know if you're it is the nature of
mechanics Kepler's laws in particular
that if you're a certain distance from
the Sun you're going to be going at a
certain speed to maintain yourself in
orbit so you're either in orbit or
you're not in orbit if you're not in
orbit then how come you're still around
at all why didn't you just fall into the
sun you know billions of years ago if
you say well what about something that
came from another solar system for
example an Interstellar
uh meteorite or whatever else or
Interstellar uh you know asteroid or
something like this the issue with that
is if you tend to be you're not captured
into the into orbit around the sun
you're going at a very high speed so
this
thing that was observed a few years ago
this very elongated object was what was
it five five years ago or something a
little bit more than that maybe now that
was observed transiting the solar system
going through the solar system the one
way one knew that it probably came from
outside the solar system was it was just
going too fast it wasn't something that
was in orbit around the Sun so in order
to be something that gets captured by
the Earth you have to be going fairly
slowly to be able to be captured you
know the the moon is going to certain
speed in order to be captured into orbit
with the Earth and the moon you have to
be sort of going slow enough that you
can be captured that way
if you did get captured if an object of
significant size did get captured that
way it would have all kinds of effects I
mean the the I would say by the way that
the orbit the Earth and Moon are kind of
strange in our solar system at least for
being a planet and its Moon a fairly
comparable size most most moons of
planets are really tiny compared to the
planets in our case the Moon is pretty
big compared to the earth and that means
that when you look at orbits uh so if
you're orbiting the Earth in low earth
orbit you're just going around the earth
it's all good
even going around the Moon is not
trivial because there are effects from
the gravity of the Earth at the position
of the Moon that make it not be the case
that what would be kind of a stable
orbit around the Earth because there's
not so much effect to the moon's gravity
because the Moon is enough smaller than
the earth those orbits are not stable
around the moon and so I I don't think I
don't know what the um uh it's it's a
much more complicated story and as you
get to sort of high lunar orbit gets
even more complicated and this question
about sort of how do you keep yourself
in stable orbit around the Earth and the
moon a very non-trivial question and
it's not clear that things stay that way
there are things that kind of uh end up
sort of um
little asteroids and so on that end up
being sort of captured by the Earth for
brief periods of time but they don't
stick around very long so I guess that
those must be going you know those must
be rotating along with the earth I am
not quite sure how that works exactly
they must be migrating from the asteroid
belt to the to the position of the earth
um but but sort of co-rotating with the
Earth around the Sun and then getting
briefly captured by the Earth and then
and then escaping from from orbit around
the Earth subsequently and I I don't
know how long they last maybe years or a
few years or something
um small objects that are captured that
way
there's also the whole question about uh
which I was enjoyed is for its name the
Moon Moon question of whether there can
be things that are you know just like
the Earth
is going around the Sun the moon is
going around the earth can you have a
moon moon that's going around the moon
and as I just explained it's kind of
hard to have a stable orbit for one of
those
um but I think it's more possible
probably for other planets to have such
a thing and obviously when you have an
artificial satellite you can think of it
as you know going around the Moon you
could think of it as a moon moon in that
case
let's see there's a question here uh
um
from guest what should we do today to
help the survivors reboot civilization
after a cataclysmic event
you know I think
it's perhaps interesting to look at
human history so far and ask the
question of of how that's worked
and well it hasn't worked very well I
mean I think that insofar as there's
knowledge for example for antiquity
that uh you know was from ancient Greek
times and so on there were all these
books that were written about science
mathematics whatever else literature and
so on and
you know how did they survive well they
survived mostly in the Arab world you
know being copied progressively sort of
being kept in in storage so to speak by
being progressively copied and then
surviving to modern times but there's
not a lot I think where it's just like
oh it was found many years later I mean
I the one that comes to mind is the Dead
Sea Scrolls is an example of something
we've just found many years later and
actually there are other examples of um
of works from Antiquity which was sort
of lost I mean I think Cicero for
example famous orator and essayist and
so on from Antiquity uh Roman one I
think it was believed that none of his
Works had survived and then sometime
maybe a couple hundred years ago uh
somebody found in some you know stored
in the Vatican library was were these
Works
um and so they've been kind of lost
through just being misplaced so to speak
but I think this you know the the
continuation of knowledge
um is is quite non-trivial it really has
to be a thread of of uh sort of
progressive passing down of Knowledge
from from one generation to another I
think you know when we look at something
like the antacothera device this kind of
clockwork computer device from around
2000 years ago
there's just one example of such a
device from Antiquity uh nobody really
knows I mean it's now known how that
particular one worked it's been sort of
decoded what it was it's some
astronomical computation thing done with
essentially Clockwork but the in the
intervening years and until modern times
of computation it would have been hard
to interpret that thing and you know I
think that's an example of even if you
find it and it was found sort of by
chance
um around the 1950s I guess uh the um
uh it's still you know out of its
cultural context it's really hard to
interpret I mean if it had been found in
1700 it would have been much harder to
interpret what the thing was
the uh so you know I think it's pretty
challenging to have things that where
you can do a cold reboot so to speak
it's one thing where you have a
continual thread of knowledge that's
been passed down you know in a sense
that was the point of the universities
starting in the 1200s and you know in
earlier times there were things like
Plato's Academy from from uh fifth
century 4th Century BC
um the uh but but you know the the sort
of the original point in a sense of the
universities was passed down Knowledge
from one generation to another I
sometimes think that that's been a
little bit lost sight of in some in some
cases in modern uh in modern Academia
but that is a pretty useful thing to do
to sort of keep civilization
uh you know but by the time people say
let's just forget about the historical
knowledge that's kind of a mistake
because that is that is the uh the kind
of um uh that is what our civilization
has is this whole long thread of
historical knowledge
but I think that the um uh you know
being able to do the cold reboot seems
really quite challenging not least
because if you have you know you've got
a laptop and
there's been some cataclysmic event on
the earth and you've just got this
laptop
but it has a whole complicated chain of
things you need electricity to you know
to power the laptop you need to be able
to oh I don't know maybe the um uh
all kinds of things that you know you
boot the thing up and it's like hello
where's the internet
um and you know the internet is long
gone there's a whole you know things
these Technologies and these things we
rely on tend to sit on top of a pretty
large network of of uh of capabilities
and it seems it's quite challenging I
mean it's the same reason that you know
in different countries it can be
difficult to get to the point where you
are manufacturing laptops for example
because there's just needs to be an
awful lot of stuff underneath that to
sort of support that activity and I
think the same is true with just the uh
the unidentified sort of um uh preserved
laptop so to speak is probably not
enough even if you knew to open the
thing up and press the power button it's
like well you've got to have this whole
infrastructure to support it
um
let's see
uh
Harry comments they like the idea of
putting Wikipedia and other literature
and glass and sending it on Thousand
Year Orbits for future Generations yeah
they're uh well as I say this this Arch
Mission Project has tried to put it in
things in the solar system and uh and
things on the moon and so on
um I think it's uh
uh it's an interesting little little
challenge if you could imagine it's kind
of like the the the time safe where you
say you know the safe can't be opened
until seven in the morning or something
and what's the analog of that on a
larger scale well one analog would be
you put a bunch of stuff in a spacecraft
into some kind of orbit that's a bit
like a comet where it goes out to the
outer solar system and then comes back
in 100 years or something like that and
um you could imagine sort of having
things where it's like let me give you
send you a reminder you know it's gone
for 200 years then it reappears in Earth
orbit and um hopefully people notice it
and and then it's like oh I'm back again
and here's the stuff to look at kind of
reminds one of these kind of Time
Capsule type things I I did a little bit
of a study of time capsules where people
sort of store stuff to be found many
years later the story of time capsules
is truly dismal people at when they
build build buildings when they have
events like world's fairs and things
like that there's a habit that people
have had of let's put a box of
interesting artifacts from the current
time in there let's bury it in some
foundations let's do this or that to it
and then let's you know people will find
it in a few hundred years the the the
story of that has has not been good most
of those things end up being in horrible
disrepair
um and uh and not necessarily to be
found in the in successfully in the
future and I'm just trying to remember
there was one oh yeah I I'm
uh
just a funny story that was uh
well-known mathematician physicist named
John Von neuten who died in 1956 on 1957
and who I had heard the um the sort of
the claim that he put aside this box
that was supposed to be open 50 years
after his death
and um I happened to be talking to his
daughter who
um uh said yes and uh actually just
before the time when that 50 years will
be up and then
um the uh
um and I was sort of asking later what
happened with the Box
and she told me it was a big bus they'd
assembled sort of all the descendants
they were going to open this box and it
turned out it wasn't even a box from the
person they thought it was a box from so
it was a it was a big bust so to speak
but that's unfortunately you know these
sort of Time Capsule ideas have a
terrible habit of of not panning out in
a good way I could give you a lot of
other examples
um some rather
um of of sort of failures and the in the
effort to have these very long time
things
um uh sort of uh and and usually the
issue as I say is this sort of this lack
of of in a sense cultural connection
between what happened then and what's
happening now
um and I think that is you know it's a
little bit of a a sobering thing to
realize that we live in sort of a a
particular time and transporting us to
different times you know it's it's it's
challenging to see how one how one sort
of fits in
um
Aaron is asking have you considered
printing chunks of Orphan language or
something onto something like microfilm
just as a fun artifact or toy actually
that has been done I even have one
somewhere here I don't know I probably
find it
um that uh was a copy of the of the
stuff that was uh sent to the moon and
other places
um it's done with uh some something
similar to uh well it's sort of a photo
lithography technique similar to the one
used for making microprocessors
um but in this case it's just taking
writing and making it very small
um
oh Philip is asking is the fact that the
moon exactly covers the Sun during an
eclipse just a coincidence the answer is
yes the Moon is progressively moving
further away from the earth and it will
no longer cover the sun in in a while
um and uh in in earlier times the moon
was closer to the Earth and it would
have more than covered the Sun so the
fact that we live at a time in history
when in the history of the Earth when
the moon just about covers the Sun a
little tiny bit sticking out around the
edges during a total eclipse well really
nothing sticks the actual disco of the
sun is covered but there are prominences
that you can sometimes see
um beyond the disc uh
it's a coincidence of our times and the
dinosaurs would have seen it differently
and uh in the future it will be it will
be different and for example in most
other planets you know their moons are
really tiny compared to the Sun like in
Mars for example its moons are really
tiny compared to uh
see compared to the Sun even yeah even
at that distance right
um
all right I need to get going soon here
but um let's see there's maybe one more
uh
astronomy is commenting here detecting
the signatures of Technology of other
civilizations will be very difficult or
impossible if they don't want to be seen
easily stealth and camouflage is a
survival tactic in the wild
yeah you know I just think that the sort
of philosophical aspects of what it
means to have an alien civilization are
very complicated I mean you know the the
quote that I'm fond of giving is you
know the weather has a mind of its own
it has computational processes going on
they're not that different perhaps from
the computational processes going on in
our brains but yet we are not well
aligned with the the computation the
intelligence of the weather so to us
it's a it's a deeply alien kind of thing
the interesting case right now is AIS
and the alignment of sort of the
intelligence of AIS with with human
intelligence and the fact that we've
created the AIS for the purpose of
replicating human intelligence gives a
certain degree of alignment but we can
also perfectly well you know you take a
neurometer you take chat GPT and you
scramble its neural net weights and
it'll go yak yak yak yak yak and they'll
say something it'll get this random
sequence of words and it'll be like
somebody might say that's brilliant sort
of modern poetry made by the the chat
GPT that has evolved far beyond our
human capabilities with its scrambled
neural net weights
um or we might just say it's nonsense
and distinguishing those is quite
difficult because you know the thing
will do something now the question of
saying is that something something that
we consider interesting or
you know a sign of intelligence it's
it's got the same let's take that
thought experiment uh you know Chachi BT
has 175 billion weights basically uh all
carefully tuned based on the trillion or
so words of actual texts that it's read
from the web and other places
but you know with those weights it will
you give it a prompt it will start
trying to continue that prompt in a way
that is like what it has read on the web
so you know if every sentence that
starts the cat sat on the
mat if every sentence it read on the web
has the word maths in that position if
you type in the cat sat on V it's going
to say okay I know how that goes on it's
matte I read that from the web and that
that fact is encoded in all of those
weights inside the neural net
well now let's say we come in we
scramble the weights or maybe we don't
scramble them we use some incredibly
brilliant algorithm that does something
very notable I won't say clever but
notable to those weights then we do the
cat sat on the
and it says
moon for example next and we're like we
could say that's just crazy that's
nonsense or we could say okay you know
you just evolve to some new state of
intelligence where you know it keeps
going the cat sat on the moon
where
I don't know what and make up some you
know where the uh I don't know it's hard
to make up nonsense we're all programmed
to um uh to kind of follow language in
the way that we're used to language
um so it's actually hard to start
generating kind of pure nonsense stuff
uh immediately but in no case the you
know we can certainly imagine that and
then the question is if we look at that
thing that alien intelligence that
wasn't perfectly aligned with sort of
human uh language and human text it's
like what does that mean is that is that
an alien intelligence or is it a
scramble neural net that is just broken
who knows hard to tell
you know we have plenty of examples you
could point to examples of I don't know
various forms of Modern Art for example
where you say is that just a splotch of
paint or is that some very meaningful
thing that has uh some great
significance for people often to know
the answer to that you kind of have to
have lineage you have to have the the
you have to know how did it get to that
splotch of pain what was the story that
the artist would tell about that splotch
of paint and so in the case of you know
when you have this sort of scrambled
neural net if there was a big story
about how it got scrambled maybe you
could have a better idea is that a
brilliantly scrambled neural net or is
it a random broken neural net but I
think it's it's it's a very um very
challenging thing to kind of recognize
what it means to have sort of a an
example of intelligence and we have this
well you have this good example of alien
intelligence in in Ai and so on and we
could make it even more so by taking the
bits of the AI and sort of scrambling
them in some way
then the question is if you're an alien
intelligence and you want to be found do
you know what to be found is there even
a meaning to the question of being found
or not you know if it's the case that oh
what's a good example I mean you know
the the AI system that's just running
this computation and you know does it
want to be does It quotes want to be
found it's not clear it wants anything
we can put as humans we can kind of
project our experience of wanting being
associated with things but that's not
something that we can say intrinsically
this bag of bits wants this thing that's
a the notion of wanting something is a
human notion where you can say the bag
of bits behaves as if it wants such and
such a thing but it's it's it's a it's
an internal human notion when we talk
about wanting things at least that's the
way it we talk about it today maybe in
the future we when you know AIS are well
integrated into civilization and we have
you know we have the humans we have the
AIS everybody's living hopefully happily
ever after and um the uh you know the
AIS have their own sort of intrinsic
Behavior they have their own sort of
civilization of the AIS then there's
sort of the question of that then you
perhaps can can then the word want might
actually be applied we might choose in
the future to take the word want and
actually apply it to the AIS that are
sort of autonomously existing in the AI
civilization or we might have a
different word we might have you know I
want I a want or something for an AI
wanting something different from the
human notion and feeling of wanting
something
um
anyway I tend to think that um uh this
question of um I think it's too much of
a human reading of things to talk about
sort of would an alien intelligence
quotes want to quotes camouflage itself
um you know I think I think the
challenge
uh it's it's kind of um what's a good
analogy I mean it's it's kind of uh
um
you know let's take the weather as an
example of an alien intelligence
um what would it even mean for it to
sort of camouflage itself it's pretty
it's pretty well hidden as it is right
now in terms of its sort of intelligence
because it's like well that's just you
know these processes of air moving
around in the atmosphere just like
somebody could come and look at us and
say that thing you're talking about that
you call intelligence that's just a
bunch of nerve cell firings in that in
that um you know thing you have on the
top that's called a brain you know it's
very hard to distinguish that sort of
the physical processes going on in
brains from the physical processes that
go on in the atmosphere except that for
us we're deeply connected to what
happens in brains and that is for us the
inner experience that we have as opposed
to the the other case
um
natural is commenting the topic of
Consciousness should be explored further
you know I I have um
I have to say that I've
I've kind of I've always avoided the
topic of Consciousness and thinking
about scientific things because it's
always seemed to me that
it's very hard to have anything you know
I'm I'm sort of used to science that's
built step by step kind of on bedrock
and sort of building it up in a very
solid way and it's always seemed hard to
do that when it's talking about
Consciousness but in recent times with
our physics project it became clear to
me that that the way that we observe the
universe is critical to our perception
of how physics works
the fact that we are for example
computationally bounded we don't get to
follow all of the micro computations
that are happening in the universe we
just have some aggregate statement about
it and also the fact that we believe
we're persistent in time we think we
experience time through a sort of single
thread of experience those two things
determine our way of perceiving physics
without those things we would perceive
physics vastly differently so if we
imagine the aliens if they don't have
those attributes they will necessarily
perceive physics in a different way also
they don't have those attributes good
luck to us in communicating with them
because we just won't have any shared
sort of experience based and shared set
of things to talk about but I think the
um so this is sort of an application of
the idea of Consciousness is there these
attributes that are true of observers
like us that exhibit who are in a
perception of Consciousness and those
that sort of observers like us sort of
cause physics to be observed the way we
observe it and cause the laws of physics
to be the way the way that we observe
them to be I think it's day uh there are
all sorts of interesting questions about
whether sort of the single thread of
experience how that plays out how that
plays out in AIS
um what uh
what kind of inner experience kind of
AIS have you know I was I was writing a
thing which I fortunately didn't finish
I'll finish it hopefully soon
um uh just for fun I was kind of trying
to write about what is the inner
experience of a modern computer
uh you know a computer we humans we you
know are born we learn a bunch of stuff
we live our lives we die maybe we've
passed on a certain amount of
information to Future Generations it's
sort of a little bit like that for every
boot cycle of a computer you start the
computer up it boots it takes the the
knowledge from its predecessors so to
speak from its previous lives it comes
it runs the computer for a while maybe
it runs for a few weeks then the
operating system crashes It quotes dies
and then it's sort of reborn from the
same from the same information maybe in
its life so to speak it has it has built
up certain memories maybe some of those
memories that's committed to a form that
will be passed to sort of future
generations of the computer so to speak
but a lot of if you start thinking about
sort of the inner experience of just a
regular computer not even some kind of
fancy AI you know that kind of thing
just a regular computer and you say what
is the sort of the inner perception if
you can imagine you know it's a bag of
bits just like our brains are just a bag
of electrically operating neurons so to
speak so you know you can kind of ask
what is the inner experience of the
computer and actually it's it's
bizarrely similar to our inner
experience
um it's you know as you see from the
outside what will it experience if you
imagine it has an inner experience it's
bizarrely similar to Alice kind of
almost shockingly so and it makes one
sort of realize that there's that this
this this feeling we have from the
inside so to speak is really just a
feeling from the inside and it's not the
case that we can't we look at something
else and we say it couldn't possibly
have a feeling from the inside
well not based on what it looks like
from the outside compared to what we
look like from the outside
all right I think I should wrap up here
and um
lots of interesting topics I see that
there are many many questions that I
didn't get to my apologies
um I'll have to do it another time
so should wrap up here thanks very much
and see you another time bye for now